This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologists have always been interested in studying how we make sense of the world. Over and over, in many fields of research, one theme has recurred. What we see here and feel is not just about what's in front of us. see, hear, and feel is not just about what's in front of us. In the 1800s, early researchers began working in a branch of psychology called psychophysics. It looked at how, for example, we can easily spot a single burning candle in a dark room. But put that same candle in a brightly lit room and the flame can be hard to spot. In other words, the context or frame around that burning candle matters. And that's true for many aspects of our lives.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantam。心理学家一直对研究我们如何理解世界很感兴趣。在许多研究领域中，一个主题反复出现。我们在这里所见、所听、所感，不仅仅是关于我们眼前的事物。在19世纪，早期研究人员开始从事心理学的一个分支，即心理物理学。它研究的是，例如，我们如何能轻易地在黑暗的房间里发现一支燃烧的蜡烛。但把同样的蜡烛放在光线充足的房间里，火焰就很难被发现。换句话说，围绕那支燃烧蜡烛的环境或框架很重要。这对我们生活的许多方面都是如此。
If you break your foot the night before your wedding, you might feel very sorry for yourself. But if all you experienced during a war is a broken foot, you would consider yourself extremely lucky. Frames also shape how we think about our jobs. This week on Hidden Brain, the second installment of our new series, Work 2.0. Last week, we looked at how many organizations failed to notice the frictions that hold them back. Today we explore how smart companies and governments are reinventing the world of work by changing the frame around it. The world of work and the world of play are different worlds. At least, they seem that way.
如果你在婚礼前一天摔断了脚，你可能会为自己感到非常难过。但如果你在战争期间经历的只是摔断了脚，你会认为自己非常幸运。框架也塑造了我们对工作的看法。本周在Hidden Brain，我们新系列“工作2.0”的第二部分。上周，我们探讨了许多组织是如何未能注意到阻碍它们发展的摩擦。今天，我们探讨聪明的公司和政府如何通过改变工作周围的框架来重塑工作世界。工作世界和游戏世界是不同的世界。至少，它们看起来是这样。
When we are at work, we are supposed to be serious. Play is the opposite of that. We play games to relax, to kick back with friends, to have fun. At the University of Pennsylvania's Wharton School, Ethan Mollick asks, if these worlds have more in common than we think, and whether the world of work has a lot to learn from the psychology of games.
当我们工作时，我们应该严肃认真。游戏则与之相反。我们玩游戏是为了放松，为了与朋友聚会，为了找乐子。在宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院，Ethan Mollick提出，如果这些世界比我们想象的有更多共同点，并且工作世界是否能从游戏心理学中学到很多东西。
Ethan Mollick, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. I want to start by talking about the ubiquity of games in our lives, Ethan. Social scientists are always talking about, would happen if a hypothetical anthropologist from Mars would pay a visit to planet Earth. And surely a visitor from another planet would notice how integral games are to human life, starting right from childhood.
Ethan Mollick，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。谢谢你邀请我。Ethan，我想从游戏中我们生活中无处不在这一点开始谈起。社会科学家总是谈论，如果一位假设的来自火星的人类学家访问地球会发生什么。肯定一位来自另一个星球的访客会注意到游戏对人类生活是多么不可或缺，从童年就开始了。
It's actually quite remarkable. Yeah, I mean, we are a game playing people. That's a definition of humanity, actually. So we have evidence that we've played games through history, and obviously games are how we learn as a kid, games are how we relax, how we compete with each other. So it really is ubiquitous feature of being human. And if you extend the world of gaming to include sports,
这实际上非常了不起。是的，我的意思是，我们是一个玩游戏的民族。这实际上是人类的一个定义。所以我们有证据表明我们在整个历史中都在玩游戏，显然游戏是我们小时候学习的方式，游戏是我们放松的方式，是我们互相竞争的方式。所以它确实是作为人类的一个无处不在的特征。如果你把游戏世界扩展到包括体育运动，
we spend huge amounts of time not just playing recreational sports and watching sports, but arguing about sports, dissecting it, engaging with it. Exactly. This is a thing we all care about. We've cared for a long time. There's actually graffiti in the great pyramids that suggest that there was actually game playing among the various groups that were building the pyramids. The pyramids
我们花费大量时间不仅是进行娱乐性运动和观看体育比赛，还在争论体育、剖析它、参与其中。没错。这是我们大家都关心的事情。我们已经关心了很长时间。大金字塔上实际上有涂鸦，表明在建造金字塔的各个群体之间实际上存在游戏活动。金字塔
appear to have been built at least in part by drafted labor and they were divided teams with names like the Friends of Kufu or the Drunkards of Minkari and compete with each other to haul the most blocks and get beer as a reward for being the winner. So games have been with us in a motivating factor for a very long time. Now these days Ethan there's one type of game that dwarfs all the others and those of course are video games. Can you give me some sense of the scale of the popularity of video games? I think one of my favorite stats is actually from a very popular game that you probably heard of called Fortnite. And at its peak of popularity during the pandemic, last year, people played 3.2 billion hours of Fortnite
似乎至少部分是由征召的劳动力建造的，他们被分成小组，名字如“胡夫之友”或“门卡拉的醉汉”，并互相竞争以搬运最多的石块，并获得啤酒作为获胜者的奖励。所以游戏作为一种激励因素已经伴随我们很长时间了。现在这些天，Ethan，有一种游戏类型让所有其他游戏相形见绌，当然那就是电子游戏。你能给我一些关于电子游戏受欢迎程度的规模感吗？我想我最喜欢的一个统计数据实际上来自一个你可能听说过的非常受欢迎的游戏，叫《堡垒之夜》。在疫情期间，去年，它的人气达到顶峰时，人们玩了32亿小时的《堡垒之夜》
in a sickle month. And just to put that in context, that's equivalent to building 29 Panama canals or 457 Empire State buildings. Wait, you're saying the amount of time people spend playing Fortnite in one month, you could build 29 Panama canals or 457 Empire State buildings? Exactly. If you could get the people to work out, a lot of them are middle schoolers, so it
在一个月内。为了说明这一点，这相当于建造29条巴拿马运河或457座帝国大厦。等等，你是说人们在一个月内玩《堡垒之夜》所花费的时间，可以建造29条巴拿马运河或457座帝国大厦？没错。如果你能让这些人去工作，他们中很多是中学生，所以
probably wouldn't be legal, but yes. Well, that's astonishing. I mean, you also cited a survey that once asked people in three Canadian cities to identify a photo of the Prime Minister of Canada and a photo of a character from a famous Nintendo video game. What did the survey find, Ethan? Oh, far more people were able to identify Mario than Stephen Harper, who was that Prime Minister at the time. I mean, that is not astonishing.
这可能不合法，但是的。嗯，那太令人震惊了。我的意思是，你还引用了一项调查，曾经要求三个加拿大城市的人识别一张加拿大总理的照片和一张著名任天堂电子游戏角色的照片。调查发现了什么，Ethan？哦，能够认出马里奥的人远多于认出斯蒂芬·哈珀的人，他当时是那位总理。我的意思是，这并不令人震惊。
I mean, people are recognizing a fictional Italian plumber in a game versus the Prime Minister of their own country. I don't think it's that surprising because of our level of engagement. Just like if you ask people to remember the circle of people in New York High School, they might have more trouble than remembering who was on their local sports team during that same period. We really connect to games as people. Now, this may be hard for people who don't play video games to understand, but
我的意思是，人们认出一个游戏中的虚构意大利水管工，而不是他们自己国家的总理。我不认为这很令人惊讶，因为我们的参与程度。就像如果你让人们记住纽约高中的人际圈，他们可能比记住同一时期当地运动队里的人更有困难。我们确实像对待人一样与游戏建立联系。现在，这对于不玩电子游戏的人来说可能很难理解，但是
the business of video games dwarfs many other industries. Can you give me a sense of the scale, the business of the video gaming industry? It's bigger than movies, it's bigger than music, it is the biggest entertainment industry by far, and it influences everywhere, right? It drives the adoption of new technologies whether it's virtual reality or the Apple App Store. It's an amazingly ubiquitous part of what we do
电子游戏的生意让许多其他行业相形见绌。你能给我一种规模感吗，电子游戏行业的生意？它比电影大，比音乐大，它是迄今为止最大的娱乐产业，它影响着各个地方，对吧？它推动了新技术的采用，无论是虚拟现实还是苹果应用商店。它是我们所做事情中一个令人惊叹的无处不在的部分
and the money flowing into it is huge. Alright, so I want to contrast what we've just heard about the world of games with the world of work. I want to play a clip from the TV show Friends, where the character Rachel expresses how many people feel about the world of work. Oh God, I hate my job. I hate my job.
而且流入其中的资金是巨大的。好吧，所以我想对比一下我们刚才听到的关于游戏世界和工作世界的内容。我想播放一段电视剧《老友记》的片段，其中角色瑞秋表达了许多人对工作世界的感受。哦，天哪，我讨厌我的工作。我讨厌我的工作。
I hate it. I don't know, honey, I'm sorry. Oh, I would have quit. But hate it. I hate my job. I hate it. I don't know, honey. I'm sorry. Oh, I would have quit. But then I think I should stick it out. Then I think why would such a person stay in such a demeaning job just because it's remotely related to the field they're interested in? Now, many, many people feel like Rachel, don't they, Ethan? Yeah, I mean, work is full of frustrations and things that make it feel meaningless
我讨厌它。我不知道，亲爱的，我很抱歉。哦，我本该辞职的。但我讨厌它。我讨厌我的工作。我讨厌它。我不知道，亲爱的。我很抱歉。哦，我本该辞职的。但后来我想我应该坚持下去。然后我想，为什么这样的人会留在一份如此贬低人的工作中，仅仅因为它与他们感兴趣的领域有某种微弱的联系？现在，许多许多人感觉像瑞秋一样，不是吗，Ethan？是的，我的意思是，工作充满了挫折和让人感觉毫无意义的事情
or a treadmill. And even if you're enjoying your job, I think everyone has times where they wonder, is this what I'm really doing with my life? I remember talking with the late anthropologist, David Grayberg sometime ago, Ethan, he told me that vast numbers of people believe that jobs were not just boring, but pointless that if that jobs disappear tomorrow, no one would notice. And it sounded like a terribly sad commentary on what work feels like for many people. Yeah, I think that many people don't feel meaning in their work. They don't feel a connection to a bigger picture, and that can be incredibly demotivating. Now, the life of a Wharton school professor sounds very exciting, but surely you must have some
或者像跑步机一样。即使你喜欢你的工作，我想每个人都有时候会想，这就是我生活中真正要做的事情吗？我记得不久前与已故人类学家大卫·格雷伯交谈，Ethan，他告诉我，大量的人认为工作不仅无聊，而且毫无意义，如果工作明天消失，没有人会注意到。这听起来是对许多人工作感受的一种非常悲伤的评论。是的，我认为许多人在工作中没有感受到意义。他们没有感受到与更大图景的联系，这可能会非常令人沮丧。现在，沃顿商学院教授的生活听起来非常令人兴奋，但你肯定也有一些
points in your life when you feel like your own life is marked by drudgery and boredom and repetition. Oh, absolutely. I mean, I just like anyone else, I had a series of jobs before becoming a professor that were quite tedious, ranging from sorting, broken computer equipment to cleaning up parking lots at shopping centers. So this was before we had podcasts, right? So it was just the radio you were listening to. And it was both gross and boring. So you start to turn work into a game. So I was, how many cigarette butts can I get in my scoop
你生命中的时刻，当你觉得自己的生活充满了苦差事、无聊和重复。哦，绝对。我的意思是，就像其他人一样，我在成为教授之前做过一系列非常乏味的工作，从分拣损坏的计算机设备到清理购物中心的停车场。所以这是在我们有播客之前，对吧？所以你听的只是收音机。而且它既恶心又无聊。所以你开始把工作变成游戏。所以我当时想，我能在我的铲子里装多少烟头
before I have to empty it out? Can I get one of each kind of garbage before this song is over? So, you know, making up games and challenges to turn this boring work into something at least somewhat more interesting. And what about in your current day job, I mean, do you experience drudgery at all or is it unending excitement? Well, as much as I'd like to say, being a professor's unending excitement, there are aspects of the job
在必须倒掉之前？我能在歌曲结束前收集到每种垃圾各一个吗？所以，你知道，编造游戏和挑战，把这些无聊的工作变成至少稍微有趣一点的事情。那么你现在的工作呢，我的意思是，你完全没有经历过苦差事吗，还是无尽的兴奋？嗯，尽管我很想说，当教授是无尽的兴奋，但工作中确实有一些方面
where that's cleaning giant data sets or sitting through some of the particularly long meetings that we sometimes have in some committees, though I probably shouldn't admit that on podcasts, but they could feel a bit tedious, yes. So Ethan, we've looked at how many people love games and fun and many people think of work as being you know, drudgery or repetition. But again, looking from the perspective of that anthropologist from Mars, there's a paradox here which is many dimensions of games look a lot like work. Talk to me about the Sims.
比如清理庞大的数据集，或者参加我们在某些委员会中偶尔会有的特别冗长的会议，虽然我不应该在播客上承认这一点，但它们确实会让人感到有点乏味，是的。所以Ethan，我们已经看了很多人喜欢游戏和乐趣，而很多人认为工作是，你知道，苦差事或重复。但再次从那位火星人类学家的角度来看，这里有一个悖论，那就是游戏的许多维度看起来很像工作。跟我谈谈《模拟人生》。
So the Sims is incredibly popular, sort of life simulator. So you build families, you build houses, you have people living these houses and kind of go through their daily jobs. And people use this for all sorts of reasons, sort of a living dollhouse. But what always amazed me at the Sims is how much time people are willing to spend just setting things up kind of correctly. So for example, people have recreated
所以《模拟人生》非常受欢迎，是一种生活模拟器。所以你建立家庭，你建造房子，你让人们住在这些房子里，并经历他们的日常工作。人们出于各种原因使用它，就像一个活生生的玩具屋。但我对《模拟人生》总是感到惊讶的是，人们愿意花多少时间只是为了把事情设置得正确。例如，人们重新创造了
the entire Akea catalog, including historical Akea shares. So you can decorate your house exactly the way you would your dorm or your other home. And it's amazing. People will spend hours just getting haircuts right. So the kinds of things that we do on a regular basis other home. And it's amazing. We will spend hours just getting haircuts right. So, you know, the kinds of things that we do on a regular basis in our daily lives, people are happy to recreate in these virtual worlds as well. But isn't it interesting that in our daily lives,
整个宜家目录，包括历史上的宜家椅子。所以你可以像装饰你的宿舍或其他家一样准确地装饰你的房子。这太神奇了。人们会花几个小时只是为了把发型弄好。所以，我们在日常生活中所做的那些事情，人们也很乐意在这些虚拟世界中重新创造。但有趣的是，在我们的日常生活中，
these often feel like chores. So, you know, if you're telling your teenager to clean up her room or get her room in order, that feels like a chore, but to design a room on a virtual game sounds like fun. Exactly. And that is the sort of paradox at the heart of trying to connect games and work, right? Is that work is often tedious and the same thing in a game can be made to be terrific. I want to look at a few other dimensions of this paradox, Ethan. Games like, you know, chutes and ladders, and I don't know how many people play those
这些通常感觉像是家务。所以，你知道，如果你告诉你的十几岁的孩子打扫她的房间或整理她的房间，那感觉像是一件苦差事，但在虚拟游戏中设计一个房间听起来很有趣。没错。这就是试图连接游戏和工作的核心悖论，对吧？工作往往是乏味的，而在游戏中同样的事情可以变得非常棒。我想看看这个悖论的其他几个维度，Ethan。像，你知道，滑梯和梯子这样的游戏，我不知道有多少人玩那些
anymore, but there are many games where we routinely, you know, playutes and ladders, and I don't know how many people play those anymore, but there are many games where we routinely, you know, play the game for a while, and then suddenly find ourselves back at square one, and now we have to, you know, march all the way back again, you know, to get back to where we were. So we constantly, in many aspects of games, have to deal with the kind of setbacks that in the real world, you know, strike us as real tedious. Well, there's even a word for this in the game world, which is grind. So the idea of grinding is putting in tremendous amounts of work to advance
了，但有很多游戏我们经常，你知道，玩游戏玩了一会儿，然后突然发现自己回到了原点，现在我们必须，你知道，一路走回去，你知道，回到我们原来的地方。所以我们不断地，在游戏的许多方面，必须处理那种在现实世界中，你知道，让我们感到非常乏味的挫折。嗯，在游戏世界里甚至有一个词来形容这个，那就是“磨练”（grind）。所以磨练的概念就是投入大量的工作来推进
your character or your game state to some degree. And there's all kinds of games include grind. You might spend 30 or 40 hours sometimes to just be able to get access to a particularly good looking piece of equipment or to upgrade your skill and fishing in an online game. So this sort of approach is really common. We see people being willing to go back to square one and start over again over and over. In fact, some of my favorite games are these type of games called Roguelikes where the whole idea is you keep failing.
你的角色或你的游戏状态到某种程度。而且各种各样的游戏都包括磨练。你有时可能要花30或40个小时才能获得一件特别好看的装备，或者在在线游戏中升级你的钓鱼技能。所以这种方法真的很常见。我们看到人们愿意回到原点，一次又一次地重新开始。事实上，我最喜欢的一些游戏是这类被称为Roguelikes的游戏，整个想法就是你不断失败。
You might fail hundreds of times before you succeed once or twice. And it's one of my favorite categories. I find that there's something, you know, failure in the real world is really difficult and painful. And failure in games can kind of be a sort of release where you get to try again and try and be more perfect the next time around. Now, I mentioned David Graber's research a second ago into how many people find that work to be pointless.
你可能在成功一两次之前失败数百次。这是我最喜欢的类别之一。我发现有一些，你知道，现实世界中的失败真的很困难和痛苦。而游戏中的失败可以成为一种释放，你可以尝试再次尝试，并在下一次尝试变得更完美。现在，我刚才提到了大卫·格雷伯关于多少人发现工作毫无意义的研究。
So this is not the dimension of the paradox because almost by definition games are pointless. You know, whether you end up with more green cones than red cones or kill the pink dragon or manage to land the ball inside the line, if you apply the same logic that people bring to their work, you can say, you know, who cares? It's pointless. Yet somehow when it comes to games, this pointlessness is somehow appealing instead of demoralizing. No one, no one ever says, okay, I captured the flag, who cares, it's pointless. Yeah, we have a category in our heads of sort of feelings of accomplishment we get from games are real, even if the experience isn't. So I think you're highlighting really nicely this kind of contrast between the fact that our real life experiences, even though they actually matter in the world, often don't
所以这不是悖论的维度，因为几乎根据定义，游戏是毫无意义的。你知道，无论你最终得到更多的绿色圆锥体还是红色圆锥体，或者杀死了粉红色的龙，或者设法把球投进线内，如果你应用人们带到工作中的相同逻辑，你可以说，你知道，谁在乎呢？它是毫无意义的。然而，当涉及到游戏时，这种无意义感不知何故是吸引人的，而不是令人沮丧的。没有人，从来没有人说，好吧，我夺取了旗帜，谁在乎，它是毫无意义的。是的，我们在脑海中有一个类别，即我们从游戏中获得的成就感是真实的，即使体验不是。所以我认为你很好地突出了这种对比，即我们的现实生活体验，尽管它们在世界上确实很重要，但往往感觉不到
feel like there's a point. Well, the things where we know they don't matter in the world, we get satisfaction out of them. And I think that that is one of the most interesting aspects of games. So we've looked at how games often involve similar kinds of repetition and setbacks and drudgery that lots of people experience at work. There is another aspect of games that also looks a lot like work. Games often demand intense effort.
有什么意义。嗯，那些我们知道它们在世界上不重要的事情，我们却从中获得了满足感。我认为这是游戏最有趣的方面之一。所以我们已经看了游戏通常如何涉及类似的工作中的重复、挫折和苦差事，很多人在工作中都有这种体验。游戏的另一个方面看起来也很像工作。游戏通常需要强烈的努力。
Now some of the earliest games we learn to play as children involve physical activity running and many of us continue to pursue these activities into adulthood. I want to play a clip from the 2019 Boston Marathon, where the commentators are talking about an athlete approaching the finish line after running more than 26 miles. What a finish to see that.
现在我们小时候学习玩的一些最早的游戏涉及身体活动，跑步，我们许多人成年后继续从事这些活动。我想播放一段2019年波士顿马拉松的片段，评论员正在谈论一位运动员在跑了超过26英里后接近终点线。看到那个终点真是太棒了。
I mean, you could just see going to everything, arms, legs, and everything is shot. So painful. I kind of feared for Decyse that he might rip his hamstring muscles. He was straining so hard at the finish. And he knew it was going to come to that. You could see.
我的意思是，你可以看到他全身都在用力，手臂、腿和一切都耗尽了。太痛苦了。我有点担心Decyse，他可能会撕裂他的腿筋肌肉。他在终点线时非常吃力。他知道会变成那样。你可以看到。
I mean, surely, Ethan, the anthropologists from Mars would say, these kinds of activities don't look like fun. And yet, tens of thousands of people voluntarily sign up to do them over and over again. and think of these activities as being, you know, some of the most meaningful achievements in their life. I think it goes back to what you discussed earlier, which is that, you know, meaning is in our work is about how we feel about this, right? And when we play games, there's some degree of, we get to pick the competition that we're
我的意思是，肯定，来自火星的人类学家会说，这些活动看起来不像是有趣的。然而，成千上万的人自愿报名一次又一次地做这些事情，并认为这些活动是，你知道，他们生活中最有意义的成就之一。我认为这回到了你之前讨论的内容，即，你知道，工作中的意义在于我们对它的感受，对吧？当我们玩游戏时，有某种程度的，我们有机会选择我们所处的竞争，
in, and we pick competitions that are meaningful for us. And there is this sense of accomplishment and joy that comes with achieving goals that you set for yourself. Right, even if those goals might seem meaningless to the outside world. I mean, do you do this yourself, Ethan? I mean, do you do this when you're working out, for example, or when you arrive, I don't know if you're a runner,
我们选择对我们有意义的竞争。当你实现自己设定的目标时，会有一种成就感和快乐。没错，即使这些目标在外界看来可能毫无意义。我的意思是，你自己做这个吗，Ethan？我的意思是，当你锻炼时，例如，或者当你到达，我不知道你是否是一个跑步者，
or a swimmer? Do you sort of set artificial targets for yourself and derive inordinate pleasure when you meet those targets? Well, I have those targets. I'm a big Apple Watch workout user, but there's another dimension that I think you've hinted at throughout our conversations, which is a lot of this involves other people, right, where that sports or marathon running, you want to beat someone else. So for me, it's one of my sisters and I,
或者游泳者？你是否会为自己设定人为的目标，并在达到这些目标时获得过度的快乐？嗯，我有那些目标。我是Apple Watch锻炼的大用户，但我认为你在我们的对话中暗示了另一个维度，那就是这其中很多涉及其他人，对吧，无论是体育还是马拉松跑步，你都想打败别人。所以对我来说，是我和我的一个姐妹，
since the pandemic, have been competing weekly for exercise on the Apple Watch. And I will keep an eye on it when she inevitably starts beating me. I have gone downstairs to work out at 11.30 at night to get those last 20 minutes in to try and overcome report total, even though I think that it scores currently
自疫情以来，我们每周都在Apple Watch上竞争锻炼。当她不可避免地开始打败我时，我会留意它。我曾在晚上11点30分下楼锻炼，以获得最后20分钟，试图克服总分，尽管我认为目前的分数
like 44 weeks to five weeks or something like that where she's one. But every time I pull it off, I feel great. It's astonishing that people will exercise in order to have a metric on their watch or to beat somebody else instead of exercising to save their own lives. I mean, you would think that the latter would have more appeal. Except that saving our lives is a slow process and beating my sister is happening now. And there's a big
大约是44周对5周左右，她赢了。但每次我成功时，我都感觉很棒。令人惊讶的是，人们会为了手表上的指标或打败别人而锻炼，而不是为了挽救自己的生命而锻炼。我的意思是，你会认为后者会有更大的吸引力。除非挽救我们的生命是一个缓慢的过程，而打败我姐妹是现在正在发生的事情。而且这两者之间有很大的
difference between those and that's a big problem with the work issue too, right? Your accomplishments are all for the future, but you know, when you blow up an alien, you're blowing it up right now. The world of play and the world of work have a lot in common. They can both involve painstaking effort and repetitive tasks. Yet, many people pay money to do one set of activities and resent doing the other, even though they get paid to do it. When we come back, we uncover the psychology behind this paradox and what it tells us about how to make work more rewarding and perhaps even fun.
区别，这也是工作问题的一个大问题，对吧？你的成就都是为了未来，但你知道，当你炸掉一个外星人时，你现在就在炸掉它。游戏世界和工作世界有很多共同点。它们都可能涉及艰苦的努力和重复的任务。然而，许多人付钱去做一套活动，却对做另一套活动感到怨恨，尽管他们因为做那件事而得到报酬。当我们回来时，我们揭示这个悖论背后的心理学，以及它告诉我们关于如何让工作更有回报，甚至可能更有趣的事情。
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Think back to when you were a kid. Ask yourself, did anyone have to force you to play games? If you were like most kids, the answer is, of course not. Whether it was a game of tag or soccer or Minecraft, you often had to be torn away from games by your parents or teachers. Think for a moment about how different that is from the world of what we call work. Managers hovering over you, teachers yelling at you, people showering you with threats and inducements to stay on task. At the Wharton School, Ethan Mollick teaches innovation and entrepreneurship. He studies why games have a radically different
你正在收听Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantam。回想一下你小时候。问问自己，有人必须强迫你玩游戏吗？如果你像大多数孩子一样，答案是，当然不是。无论是捉人游戏、足球还是《我的世界》，你经常不得不被你的父母或老师从游戏中拉开。想一想这与我们所谓的“工作”世界有多么不同。经理在你身边盘旋，老师对你大喊大叫，人们用威胁和诱惑让你保持专注。在沃顿商学院，Ethan Mollick教授创新和创业。他研究为什么游戏对我们的思想有着与工作截然不同的
effect on our minds than work. Ethan, we talked about how many games aren't all that different from jobs in that they can also involve repetitive, boring, or difficult activities. But there are many psychological differences between work and play. And what do them has to do with the way games often incorporate stories? Can you tell me how games use storytelling
影响。Ethan，我们谈到了许多游戏在涉及重复、无聊或困难活动方面与工作并没有什么不同。但工作和游戏之间有许多心理差异。其中一个与游戏经常结合故事的方式有关吗？你能告诉我游戏是如何使用讲故事来保持我们的兴趣的吗？
to hold our interest? Definitely. So our lives at work often don't fit a neat narrative, right? Where not hero, we're not villain, there's not a story of progression, we have to do that for ourselves. But humans are kind of narrative machines, we've always told stories, and games are great because they give you a context or meaning for your work in that storyline. You're not just clicking a button, you're saving a planet, you're not just moving a mouse and completing some task, you are helping your team win. So there's both this sort of small scale story that we feel like we're part of that narrative.
当然。所以我们在工作中的生活往往不符合一个整洁的叙事，对吧？我们不是英雄，我们不是反派，没有进步的故事，我们必须为自己做这件事。但人类是某种叙事机器，我们一直都在讲故事，而游戏很棒，因为它们在那个故事情节中为你提供了一个工作的背景或意义。你不仅仅是在点击一个按钮，你是在拯救一个星球，你不仅仅是在移动鼠标并完成一些任务，你是在帮助你的团队获胜。所以既有这种我们觉得我们是那个叙事一部分的小规模故事。
And also the larger scale stories, many games are built around storyline, right? That you are accomplishing some goal. You're often the hero of the tale, saving the world or improving something in some way. And that's a really powerful tool because we can imagine ourselves in those positions and that makes our choices feel meaningful. The connection that you're drawing here might explain why movies lend
还有更大规模的故事，许多游戏是围绕故事情节构建的，对吧？你正在实现某个目标。你往往是故事的英雄，拯救世界或以某种方式改进某些东西。这是一个非常强大的工具，因为我们可以想象自己处于那些位置，这让我们的选择感觉有意义。你在这里建立的联系可能解释了为什么电影倾向于
themselves to games and vice versa. Like the Harry Potter movie franchise has spawned dozens of games, right? Exactly. I mean, you know, one step beyond the movie is being in the movie, right? So even though movie games have reputation for being pretty mediocre games, they're also continuously popular, not because the game plays amazing, but because you want to be Harry Potter or Ray or Luke Skywalker, whoever you want to inhabit. Something you said a moment ago really struck me, which is it's not just that games have stories, but sometimes the reward for playing a game is that you unlock new elements of
游戏，反之亦然。比如《哈利·波特》电影系列催生了数十款游戏，对吧？没错。我的意思是，你知道，超越电影的一步就是身处电影之中，对吧？所以尽管电影游戏以相当平庸的游戏而闻名，但它们也持续受欢迎，不是因为游戏玩法很棒，而是因为你想成为哈利·波特或雷伊或卢克·天行者，任何你想扮演的人。你刚才说的一件事真的打动了我，那就是不仅仅是游戏有故事，而且有时玩游戏的奖励是你解锁了故事的新元素。
the story. So playing the game becomes a way to move forward in the narrative. Can you give me an example of a game that works like this? Oh, definitely. I mean, a lot of games depend on sort of a cliffhanger or next event, and the feeling of your gaining power or gaining control is really important. So there's classic role-playing games where there's the Final Fantasy games or the Witcher, where the story is compelling. You want to find out what happens next, and your choices affect
所以玩游戏成为在叙事中前进的一种方式。你能给我一个像这样工作的游戏的例子吗？哦，当然。我的意思是，很多游戏依赖于某种悬念或下一个事件，而你获得力量或获得控制的感觉非常重要。所以有经典的角色扮演游戏，比如《最终幻想》游戏或《巫师》，故事很引人入胜。你想找出接下来会发生什么，而你的选择会影响
the world around you. Got a minute. Why not? I'm looking for a woman, long hair, dressed in black and white, seen anyone like that. Of course. I actually still have some games that I played, one called Mass Effect, that I still, you know, about six years later, think about how I made a bad choice that doomed one of my companions in the game and still regretted at this point, I should have lowered that saved game, I'm sorry Jack. Damage was contained, but Jack did not survive. I'm sorry Jack. So, games allow us to follow narratives and become entranced by stories, but they also
你周围的世界。等一下。为什么不呢？我在找一个女人，长头发，穿着黑白衣服，见过这样的人吗？当然。我实际上仍然有一些我玩过的游戏，一个叫《质量效应》，我仍然，你知道，大约六年过去了，还在想我是如何做出了一个糟糕的选择，导致我的一位同伴在游戏中丧生，至今仍感到后悔，我本该降低那个存档，对不起Jack。伤害被控制住了，但Jack没有幸存。对不起Jack。所以，游戏允许我们跟随叙事并被故事所吸引，但它们也
do something else that you hinted at a moment ago. They offer us a chance to try things out and to take chances. So, in other words, when you let down the character Jack in the game, that was painful, but presumably not as painful as letting Jack down in real life. Can you talk about how games allow us to simulate life but with lower stakes? Yeah, so we are drawn to systems and we like to be able to kind of play with systems, right? Failure is interesting and it's why flight simulators are interesting, right? The chance to fail to learn from mistakes and to try again
做了你刚才暗示的另一件事。它们为我们提供了一个尝试事物和冒险的机会。所以，换句话说，当你在游戏中让角色Jack失望时，那是痛苦的，但大概不像在现实生活中让Jack失望那么痛苦。你能谈谈游戏如何允许我们模拟生活但风险更低吗？是的，所以我们被系统所吸引，我们喜欢能够玩弄系统，对吧？失败很有趣，这就是为什么飞行模拟器很有趣，对吧？失败、从错误中学习并再次尝试的机会
is exciting things to do, right? Building sandcastles is fun. Not getting them over is actually more fun, right? The sort of destruction that playing with reality is really interesting. So games lend themselves very naturally to thinking about systems and how they break and how they fail.
是令人兴奋的事情，对吧？堆沙堡很有趣。不把它们弄倒实际上更有趣，对吧？那种玩弄现实的破坏性真的很有趣。所以游戏非常自然地倾向于思考系统以及它们如何崩溃和如何失败。
And then you get the real sense of improvement from that failure in games that you don't in real life, right? If your startup company fails, that feels pretty bad. But if it fails in a game, maybe that was interesting, and now you're gonna do something different next time. Right, so if you get killed in a game, you start over. If you lose a match, you know, you come back and play again tomorrow,
然后你从那种失败中获得了真正的改进感，这在现实生活中是没有的，对吧？如果你的初创公司失败了，那感觉很糟糕。但如果它在游戏中失败了，也许那很有趣，现在你下次会做一些不同的事情。没错，所以如果你在游戏中被杀，你重新开始。如果你输了一场比赛，你知道，你回来明天再玩，
you mess up at work, you can get fired. Exactly, and that makes us less willing to take the risks that are both important for, you know, learning. It worked like we learn from failure, but we're very afraid to fail. And even if we fail, we're afraid to publicly discuss our failure, right? Because then people might think we're not competent. So all of that holds back our advancement in the world of work. But in games, failure is interesting. Talking about failure is interesting. People make YouTube videos of the biggest disasters they had in games. So it's a very different attitude towards the world. You know, I spoke some time ago with your fellow University of Pennsylvania researcher Paul
你在工作中搞砸了，你可能会被解雇。没错，这使我们不太愿意承担那些对，你知道，学习很重要的风险。在工作中我们从失败中学习，但我们非常害怕失败。即使我们失败了，我们也害怕公开讨论我们的失败，对吧？因为那样人们可能会认为我们不称职。所以所有这些都阻碍了我们在工作世界中的进步。但在游戏中，失败很有趣。谈论失败很有趣。人们制作他们在游戏中遇到的最大灾难的YouTube视频。所以这是一种对世界非常不同的态度。你知道，我不久前与你的宾夕法尼亚大学研究员同事Paul
Rosen and he explained this concept to me called benign masochism. When you go bungee jumping or ride a roller coaster, you have an illusion of danger or pain without actual danger or pain. And in some ways, games allow us to taste what it feels like to be attacked or under siege or even killed without the real risks attended to those things. Exactly. And it's normal to sort of be curious about these things. I actually once went to a military game training convention. And I was kind of just curious about the failure states
Rosen交谈过，他向我解释了这个概念，称为“良性受虐”。当你去蹦极或坐过山车时，你有一种危险或痛苦的错觉，而没有实际的危险或痛苦。在某种程度上，游戏允许我们品尝被攻击、被围困甚至被杀的感觉，而没有伴随这些事情的真正风险。没错。而且对这些事情感到好奇是很正常的。我实际上曾经去过一个军事游戏训练大会。我只是对所有游戏的失败状态感到好奇。
for all the games. So I would play every simulator, and these were multi-million dollars simulators, and see what happened when you drove the tank off a cliff or crashed the plane. It was always boring. Although I did, I think, break one of the tank simulators by driving into a wall. And then apparently no one had ever done that before
所以我玩了每一个模拟器，这些都是数百万美元的模拟器，看看当你把坦克开下悬崖或飞机坠毁时会发生什么。它总是很无聊。虽然我确实，我想，通过撞墙打破了其中一个坦克模拟器。然后显然以前从来没有人这样做过
and it broke the game. But I think we are interested in what happens when things go wrong in these kind of cases. Yeah, and even though of course, some of that might seem destructive, this is how learning actually happens. When you break something, you actually understand something deep about how it actually works.
它打破了游戏。但我认为我们对在这些情况下事情出错时会发生什么很感兴趣。是的，即使当然，其中一些可能看起来具有破坏性，但这就是学习实际发生的方式。当你打破某些东西时，你实际上理解了关于它如何实际工作的深刻东西。
I mean, in the most basic sense, learning is about failure and about doing things better than next time. It's why testing helps us learn better. It's why a lot of my work now is about designing games to teach because you can fail in a game and advance to the future, but if you fail in real life, it's costly, right? So this idea that we learn through failure,
我的意思是，在最基本的意义上，学习是关于失败和关于比下一次做得更好。这就是为什么测试帮助我们更好地学习。这就是为什么我现在很多工作是关于设计游戏来教学，因为你可以在游戏中失败并前进到未来，但如果你在现实生活中失败，代价很高，对吧？所以这个想法，我们通过失败学习，
that we should experience more failure in our lives is actually a really good one. And there's this taunted games as get good, right? And that's something you could actually do in a game. You could practice and get good from failure. I wanna talk about another dimension of the psychology of games. You know, if you like chess,
我们应该在生活中经历更多的失败，实际上是一个非常好的想法。而且游戏中有这种嘲讽，即“变强”（get good），对吧？这是你实际上可以在游戏中做的事情。你可以练习并从失败中变强。我想谈谈游戏心理学的另一个维度。你知道，如果你喜欢国际象棋，
maybe you've tried the game, Play Magnus. It's named after the Norwegian Chester Magnus Carlson. And the conceited the game is that you can play against Magnus Carlson at 29 different skill levels, starting with playing with Magnus when he was age 5 and then age 6 and age 7. And you can see at what point, you know, Magnus Carlson starts to beat you. Ethan, tell me how well-constructed games carefully find this balance between not running too far ahead of our abilities and not running too far behind our abilities.
也许你尝试过游戏《Play Magnus》。它以挪威国际象棋选手马格努斯·卡尔森的名字命名。这个游戏的构思是，你可以在29个不同的技能水平上与马格努斯·卡尔森对弈，从与5岁时的马格努斯对弈开始，然后是6岁和7岁。你可以看到在什么点上，你知道，马格努斯·卡尔森开始打败你。Ethan，告诉我精心构建的游戏是如何小心地找到这种平衡的，即不跑得太超前于我们的能力，也不跑得太落后于我们的能力。
Well, you may have heard of the state of flow, right? This famous psychological construct that that's when time vanishes at work, right? We get into a task and everything around us disappears. Maybe we're working on a spreadsheet and everything sort of focused down and you looked up at hours it passed, it's very commonly found in sports and activities. And one of the keys to achieving that flow state is to neither be bored, because the task is too easy, nor to be frustrated, because the task is so hard. And one of the things that a well-designed game does, is it adjusts its difficulty level, right? You beat a level,
嗯，你可能听说过“心流”状态，对吧？这个著名的心理学结构，那就是时间在工作中消失的时候，对吧？我们进入一个任务，我们周围的一切都消失了。也许我们正在处理一个电子表格，一切都集中起来，你抬头看，几个小时过去了，它在体育和活动中非常常见。实现那种心流状态的关键之一是既不感到无聊，因为任务太容易，也不感到沮丧，因为任务太难。精心设计的游戏所做的事情之一是，它调整其难度级别，对吧？你打败了一个关卡，
and then you get the next hardest level. If you don't succeed, you play again until it becomes easy. And the sense of accomplishment is something that you can get in a game where everything is always calibrated to keep you in that flow state. And it's not something we get to do in reality nearly as often. So this reminds me of a concept sometimes called the Yorkies Dotson law, named after the psychologist Robert Yorkies and John Dotson. They found that people's performance increases with mental arousal and with stress, but only up to a certain point,
然后你得到下一个最难的关卡。如果你没有成功，你再次玩，直到它变得容易。成就感是你可以在游戏中获得的东西，在那里一切总是经过校准以保持你在那种心流状态。这不是我们在现实中经常能做到的事情。所以这让我想起了一个有时被称为“耶基斯-多德森定律”的概念，以心理学家罗伯特·耶基斯和约翰·多德森的名字命名。他们发现人们的表现随着精神唤醒和压力而增加，但只到一定程度，
beyond which stress becomes really detrimental, performance starts to decline, I feel that good game designers are keenly aware of the Yerkees' dots in law. Exactly, I mean, this is what the secret of games is. If you look back to the earliest sort of video game when you think about Pac-Man or Mario Brothers or whatever it is, the levels start easy, right?
超过这个程度，压力就会变得非常有害，表现开始下降，我觉得好的游戏设计师非常了解耶基斯-多德森定律。没错，我的意思是，这就是游戏的秘密。如果你回顾最早的电子游戏，当你想到《吃豆人》或《马里奥兄弟》或任何其他游戏时，关卡开始时很容易，对吧？
And they get harder and harder until you lose. And then you play again, right? They're adjusting up to your difficulty level. You get a sense of mastery and accomplishments, you go forward. So games can adjust to difficulty. Work does not adjust to difficulty, right? And work, we just keep, you know, if our tasks are boring, it's likely to be boring for a while.
它们变得越来越难，直到你输掉。然后你再次玩，对吧？它们正在调整到你的难度级别。你获得了一种掌握感和成就感，你继续前进。所以游戏可以调整难度。工作不会调整难度，对吧？在工作中，我们只是继续，你知道，如果我们的任务很无聊，它很可能会无聊一段时间。
If it's too stressful, we're stressed all the time. It wouldn't be great if work adjusted its difficulty level to keep us in the perfect level of engagement without either being too stressed or getting bored. I want to talk about another dimension of games, which is that their, you know, games often come with a clear set of rules. They give us clear feedback on where we are in the game. You know, what happens when we read certain levels, how we can improve. I mean, this is especially true in video games, but it's also true, you know, in sports. We all agree that when a goal is scored, you know, you get a
如果压力太大，我们一直处于压力之下。如果工作能调整其难度级别以保持我们在完美的参与水平，而既不会太有压力也不会感到无聊，那不是很好吗？我想谈谈游戏的另一个维度，那就是它们，你知道，游戏通常带有明确的规则集。它们给我们关于我们在游戏中的位置的明确反馈。你知道，当我们阅读某些关卡时会发生什么，我们如何改进。我的意思是，这在电子游戏中尤其如此，但在体育运动中也是如此。我们都同意，当进球时，你知道，你得到一个
point. I'm wondering whether the clarity of the rules of games, you know, even if they're artificial, allow us to engage in games without the ambiguity that often comes into play in work settings where you don't always know what the rules are or how to get ahead. Definitely. So there's clarity. We know what we're supposed to do. Even with the uncertainties or in a puzzle game, you may not know the exact answer, but you know there's an answer for you.
分。我想知道游戏规则的清晰度，你知道，即使它们是人为的，是否允许我们在没有工作环境中经常出现的模糊性的情况下参与游戏，在那里你并不总是知道规则是什么或如何领先。当然。所以有清晰度。我们知道我们应该做什么。即使在益智游戏中有不确定性，你可能不知道确切的答案，但你知道有一个答案等着你。
The second interesting thing about games is this concept that people study games called the Magic Circle, which is when people play games, they enter the Magic Circle. They agree to be bound by the rules of the game. That's why no matter how frustrating that monopoly game is, you don't break the rules and start to cheat, right? We feel like there's stakes there and we feel bound to work with each other. So that's another aspect of games is we're all sort of on the same playing fields,
关于游戏的第二个有趣的事情是人们研究游戏时称之为“魔圈”的概念，即当人们玩游戏时，他们进入了魔圈。他们同意受游戏规则的约束。这就是为什么无论那个大富翁游戏多么令人沮丧，你都不会打破规则并开始作弊，对吧？我们觉得那里有赌注，我们觉得有义务互相合作。所以这是游戏的另一个方面，我们都处于同一个竞技场上，
right? In a way that we aren't at work where you may not understand the social rules or the politics. Right. And you know, in the game, as you pointed out just a second ago, we all start off on an equal footing, which actually is an important idea here. I mean, so everyone who starts a game of chess starts with the same pieces and the same ponds. What happens then follows the rules of the game and then your creativity, but you're not starting out
对吧？以一种我们在工作中没有的方式，在那里你可能不理解社会规则或政治。没错。而且你知道，在游戏中，正如你刚才指出的，我们都站在平等的起点上，这实际上是一个重要的想法。我的意思是，所以每个开始下棋的人都从相同的棋子和相同的兵开始。接下来发生的事情遵循游戏规则，然后是你的创造力，但你不是从
with a leg up. Someone doesn't have an extra leg up just because of who they are, or what school they went to, or what their background went to or what their background or privilege might be. And that's always the great democratizing aspect of games, right? Is that it lets people sort of show their own ability or work, right? And sort of a pure setting. So, you know, that's why sports is appealing in a lot of ways. Anyone can rise up. And that's a
领先一步开始的。某人不会仅仅因为他们是谁，或者他们上了什么学校，或者他们的背景，或者他们的背景或特权可能是什么，就拥有额外的优势。这总是游戏伟大的民主化方面，对吧？它让人们展示他们自己的能力或工作，对吧？在一个纯粹的环境中。所以，你知道，这就是为什么体育在很多方面都很有吸引力。任何人都可以崛起。这就是一个
story we love is that somebody who, you know, unexpected becomes good or somebody who came from a powerster difficult background turns out to be a champion, right? And, you know, it's the same thing that happens in games as well. One of the things I've been experimenting with is can we use games to identify extraordinary talent and find people who have the capability to say be an entrepreneur that is unrecognized because of all those other social constraints that typically would hold us back, right, who we know, where we went to school, what resource we were born with. And I think there's something about that game aspect and identification of game, of talented games that is really appealing. Games use a variety of psychological techniques to grab and hold our attention, the encouraged
我们所钟爱的故事是，某个人出人意料地变得优秀，或者出身贫寒的人最终成为了冠军，对吧？你知道，游戏里也会发生同样的事情。我一直在尝试的一件事是，我们能否利用游戏来发掘非凡的人才，找到那些有能力成为企业家，却因为通常会阻碍我们的社会限制——比如我们认识谁、毕业于哪所学校、出生时拥有什么资源——而未被认可的人？我认为游戏这一方面以及对人才游戏的识别，确实非常有吸引力。游戏利用各种心理学技巧来吸引并保持我们的注意力，鼓励
exploration and learning. The best games are skillfully calibrated, so we feel stimulated without feeling overwhelmed. Now when non-gamers talk about games, it's often from a negative perspective. Parents and educators worry about kids playing addictive or violent video games. Managers worry that games can be a source of distraction in the workplace. Former New York City mayor Michael Bloomberg once fired a government employee for playing solid-terret work. When we come back, how some companies, organizations, and policy makers are taking a different tack. Instead of seeing games as the enemy, they are deploying what we have learned about the psychology of games to engage employees, entice customers and educate citizens. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan.
探索和学习。最好的游戏经过了巧妙的校准，让我们感到受刺激但又不会感到不知所措。现在，当非游戏玩家谈论游戏时，往往是从负面的角度出发。家长和教育工作者担心孩子们玩容易上瘾或暴力的电子游戏。管理者担心游戏会成为工作场所分心的来源。前纽约市长迈克尔·布隆伯格曾因一名政府雇员在工作时玩纸牌游戏而将其解雇。稍后回来，我们将探讨一些公司、组织和政策制定者是如何采取不同策略的。他们没有将游戏视为敌人，而是运用我们在游戏心理学中学到的知识来吸引员工、招揽客户并教育公民。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
Games rely on a range of psychological techniques to engage us and to keep us coming back for more. They keep score, let us roleplay, and encourage curiosity and exploration. In his book, Changing the Game, and in his day job as a management researcher at the Wharton School, Ethan Mollick studies how employers and policy makers are trying to incorporate features of games into the workplace, to promote creativity, to increase engagement, and to boost the bottom line. Ethan, research teams fighting disease often confront problems that involve mammoth amounts
游戏依靠一系列心理学技巧来吸引我们并让我们不断回流。它们会记录分数、让我们进行角色扮演，并鼓励好奇心和探索。伊森·莫利克在他的著作《改变游戏规则》中，以及作为沃顿商学院管理研究员的日常工作中，研究了雇主和政策制定者如何尝试将游戏元素融入工作场所，以促进创造力、提高参与度并提升利润。伊森，研究团队在抗击疾病时经常面临涉及海量
of very arduous work. You talk about a computer game called FoldIt that's used to come up with cures for diseases. Can you explain the challenge that games like FoldIt are designed to solve and how they work? Yeah, FoldIt represents a bunch of these really interesting games that we sometimes call Citizen Science. The idea that how do we take complex tasks and outsource them to regular people, regular citizens to solve. And Foldit is one example of this. It handles a really hard problem, which
艰巨工作的问题。你谈到了一款名为“FoldIt”的电脑游戏，它被用于寻找疾病的治疗方法。你能解释一下像FoldIt这样的游戏旨在解决什么挑战以及它们是如何运作的吗？是的，FoldIt代表了一系列我们有时称之为“公民科学”的非常有趣的游戏。其理念是，我们如何将复杂的任务外包给普通人、普通公民来解决。FoldIt就是其中的一个例子。它处理了一个非常困难的问题，即
is how do proteins fold? So we have a sense of the sort of atomic structure of protein, but the shape that it takes follows all these complex rules that have never been very easy to model until quite recently on computers. And so it's relied on scientists to try and figure out what kind of shape these proteins take, and that determines all of their properties,
蛋白质是如何折叠的？我们对蛋白质的原子结构有所了解，但它所呈现的形状遵循所有这些复杂的规则，直到最近才在计算机上变得容易建模。因此，它一直依赖科学家来尝试弄清楚这些蛋白质呈现出什么样的形状，而这决定了它们所有的特性，
what diseases they cause, how they can be used to increase energy efficiency of alternative fuels, and so on. And what is interesting is the people who go into, sell biology or into chemistry are not necessarily really great at solving three-dimensional puzzles, but there's a lot of people in the world who really great at solving three-dimensional puzzles, but there's lots of people in the world who are really good at three-dimensional puzzles who may not know science. So what Folder does is let anyone play with the structure of a protein
它们会导致什么疾病，它们如何被用于提高替代燃料的能源效率等等。有趣的是，那些从事细胞生物学或化学的人并不一定非常擅长解决三维谜题，但世界上有很多人非常擅长解决三维谜题，但他们可能不懂科学。所以FoldIt所做的是让任何人都可以摆弄蛋白质的结构，
and fold it to try and maximize a bunch of scientific characteristics. And what's cool is the citizens have come up with solutions that scientists struggled with. So, it took people more than 14 years, for example, on trying to figure out the structure of a protein in a monkey form of HIV. And the folded citizens scientists were able to come up with the answer in just weeks. So there's these kind of problems that are solvable by people through games that are not solvable in other ways. And I understand that folded has a collaborative component to it as well. Yeah, the collaborative element is really interesting, right?
并对其进行折叠，以尝试最大化一系列科学特征。酷的是，公民们想出了科学家们苦苦思索的解决方案。例如，人们花了14年多的时间试图弄清楚猴子形式的艾滋病毒中蛋白质的结构。而FoldIt的公民科学家们仅在几周内就得出了答案。所以，存在着这类可以通过游戏由人们解决，而无法通过其他方式解决的问题。我了解到FoldIt还有一个协作组件。是的，协作元素真的很有趣，对吧？
We talked earlier about how we like teams and competition. So actually, in Foldit, you're encouraged to join teams of people and those teams compete against each other on a leaderboard. And the most successful teams at folding proteins are actually the teams that don't have any formal biology training. So it's really interesting because these teams would never been drawn to the problem if it hadn't been turned into a game, but they just love solving three-dimensional puzzles. And so these street smart teams are actually beating the more scientific teams in the game. I understand that part of the reason this works
我们之前谈到过我们如何喜欢团队和竞争。所以实际上，在FoldIt中，你被鼓励加入团队，这些团队在排行榜上相互竞争。而折叠蛋白质最成功的团队实际上是那些没有任何正式生物学培训的团队。这真的很有趣，因为如果这些团队没有被转化为游戏，他们永远不会被这个问题所吸引，但他们只是喜欢解决三维谜题。所以这些街头智慧的团队实际上在游戏中击败了更专业的科学团队。我了解到这之所以有效的部分原因
is not just because some people have exceptional skills, but that the elements that we've discussed earlier about gaming allow people to invest huge amounts of time in applying themselves to problems like this. Can you talk about how some of these citizen science efforts are able to enlist volunteers not just to contribute their insights, but to contribute huge amounts of time to solving problems of public interest. Yeah, so there was another citizen science effort in a
不仅是因为有些人拥有非凡的技能，而且我们之前讨论过的关于游戏的元素允许人们投入大量时间来致力于解决这样的问题。你能谈谈这些公民科学工作是如何能够招募志愿者，不仅贡献他们的见解，而且贡献大量时间来解决公共利益问题的吗？是的，所以还有另一个公民科学工作，在
game called EVON line, which is sort of a giant Machiavellian spaceship simulation. You navigate the universe encased in an armoured capsule deep within your ship, where you have complete neural control and function as one. And you were able to solve problems by identifying images of cell structures and cell pathways. And a total of 320,000 players identified these things over a course of a year. They added tens of millions of images that have now made up the Atlas of Cell Biology, and the total amount of time they spent was equivalent to 72 years of research or time to identify these characteristics. And that's
一款名为《EVE Online》的游戏中，这是一种巨大的马基雅维利式太空飞船模拟。你驾驶着宇宙，被包裹在飞船深处的装甲舱中，在那里你拥有完全的神经控制并合二为一。你能够通过识别细胞结构和细胞通路的图像来解决问题。总共有32万名玩家在一年内识别了这些东西。他们增加了数千万张图像，这些图像现在构成了细胞生物学图谱，他们花费的总时间相当于72年的研究时间来识别这些特征。而这
because it was built into a game that people loved and cared about, and it was just integrated into their normal process. I understand some companies are using games to help them build better products. How does Microsoft encourage employees to find bugs in critical software programs? So this is a really interesting aspect of games called gamification. And gamification has sort of had ups and downs over the last two decades. But the basic idea is that you're going to take elements of things that we know work in games.
是因为它被内置在人们喜爱和关心的游戏中，并且它只是被整合到了他们的正常流程中。我了解到一些公司正在使用游戏来帮助他们构建更好的产品。微软是如何鼓励员工在关键软件程序中寻找漏洞的？所以这是游戏的一个非常有趣的方面，叫做游戏化。游戏化在过去二十年中经历了一些起伏。但基本理念是，你将采用我们知道在游戏中有效的元素。
So those leaderboards that we talked about, competition, the idea of engagement or unlocking stories, and you're going to apply those aspects to work. And Microsoft's really been a leader in doing this on their own internal teams. So they have done things that have ranged from giving people badges and awards for participation, which increased the number of people
所以我们谈到的那些排行榜、竞争、参与或解锁故事的想法，你将把这些方面应用到工作中。微软在他们自己的内部团队中确实是这方面的领导者。所以他们做了一些事情，范围从给人们提供参与的徽章和奖励，这增加了人们
who were reporting bugs in their software in the internal Microsoft Teams multiple times. They've created teams that could beat the fine bugs or issues with software when they download it, and they unlocked charity awards for their favorite charity. And so there's lots of really clever techniques that they've been applying that have all served to increase engagement in this other important bug finding but otherwise voluntary activity.
报告他们软件中漏洞的人数，在内部微软团队中多次增加。他们创建了团队，当他们下载软件时可以击败寻找漏洞或问题，并为他们最喜欢的慈善机构解锁了慈善奖励。所以他们应用了许多非常聪明的技术，所有这些都起到了增加参与度的作用，在这一重要的漏洞查找但原本是自愿的活动中。
And it's made a huge difference in their work. So the actual programs are being released sooner or with fewer bugs? With fewer bugs and faster. So if games can be used to encourage people to solve problems, they can also be used to train people in various fields. And one of the best examples of this might be a program called Top Gun. Ethan, can you explain the genesis of this game and how it works?
这在他们的工作中产生了巨大的影响。所以实际的程序发布得更早或漏洞更少了吗？漏洞更少，速度更快。所以如果游戏可以用来鼓励人们解决问题，它们也可以用来培训各个领域的人。而这最好的例子之一可能是名为“壮志凌云”（Top Gun）的项目。伊森，你能解释一下这个游戏的起源以及它是如何运作的吗？
So Top Gun is actually sort of the grandfather of games. It's actually the same Top Gun that you have seen maybe the Tom Cruise movie or the soon to come out remake of the Tom Cruise movie. The end is inevitable, Maverick. The kind has set it for station. Maybe so, sir. But not today. And it actually is sort of one of our first indications of how important sort of games and simulations are for training.
所以“壮志凌云”实际上算是游戏的鼻祖。它实际上就是你可能在汤姆·克鲁斯电影或即将上映的汤姆·克鲁斯电影翻拍版中看到的同一个“壮志凌云”。结局是不可避免的，小牛。这种类型已经设定好了。也许吧，长官。但不是今天。它实际上是我们关于游戏和模拟对于培训有多重要的最初迹象之一。
So it actually came out of the fact that the US Air Force and US Navy had been dominant pilots in air combat. From World War II up through the Korean War, and when the Vietnam War started, some American pilots were underperforming. So when there was a pause in the air war over Vietnam, both the Air Force and Navy tried to figure out how to solve this problem. The Air Force had a lot more money, so they spent money upgrading planes, putting new
所以它实际上源于这样一个事实：美国空军和美国海军在空战中一直是占主导地位的飞行员。从二战到朝鲜战争，当越南战争开始时，一些美国飞行员的表现不佳。因此，当越南上空的空战暂停时，空军和海军都试图找出解决这个问题的方法。空军有更多的钱，所以他们花钱升级飞机，安装新的
weapons in, new turning systems, and the Navy which had much less money, concentrated on a really interesting stat, which I think is really important overall, which is that the likelihood of you being shot down in air combat was highest in your first mission or two. If you could survive your first couple missions, your first critical mistakes, you were likely to keep surviving. So they wanted to figure out how do we get people to gamified
武器，新的转向系统，而钱少得多的海军则专注于一个非常有趣的统计数据，我认为这在总体上非常重要，那就是你在空战中被击落的可能性在你的第一次或两次任务中最高。如果你能熬过最初的几次任务，克服最初的关键错误，你很可能会继续生存下去。所以他们想弄清楚我们如何让人们进行游戏化
simulated experience of getting a chance to try air combat against experts in your first couple missions without getting shot down in real life And they launched top gun, which is this training school in Nevada where top Navy pilots fly enemy planes against trainees and when the air war resumed it was sort of like a natural experiment The Air Force continued to have worse and worse conditions in air combat But the Navy went back to being incredibly successful
模拟体验，在最初的几次任务中获得与专家进行空战的机会，而不会在现实生活中被击落。他们发起了“壮志凌云”，这是内华达州的一个培训学校，顶尖的海军飞行员驾驶敌机对抗学员，当空战恢复时，这就像一个自然实验。空军在空战中的条件越来越差，但海军又变得非常成功。
So there's something about that training or practice that is really important in real life, right? You don't want your pilot to be flying a plane for the first time with you in it. You don't want to be the first person for a surgeon to be experimenting on, and games can help us get to that stage where people have real experiences before they actually have to pick up a knife or fly a plane. You mentioned the example of surgery a second ago. I mean, I'm thinking about the popular children's game
所以那种培训或练习在现实生活中确实非常重要，对吧？你不想让你的飞行员第一次驾驶飞机时你就坐在上面。你不想成为外科医生实验的第一个人，而游戏可以帮助我们达到人们在真正拿起手术刀或驾驶飞机之前就拥有真实经验的阶段。你刚才提到了手术的例子。我的意思是，我正在想流行的儿童游戏
called Operation where you have to carefully remove various plastic organs with tweezers from a make-believe character. But I understand that surgeons and hospitals are actually using simulation and games to actually improve the real life skills of people performing surgeries. Absolutely. Real life surgical experiments,
叫做“手术”（Operation），你必须用镊子小心地从一个虚构的角色身上取出各种塑料器官。但我了解到外科医生和医院实际上正在使用模拟和游戏来真正提高执行手术的人的现实生活技能。绝对是。现实生活中的外科实验，
playing with games and simulations that give you the experience of surgery, is now a critical part of training doctors and surgeons. So, for example, there is a simulator that teaches you how to interact with patients where you're first a doctor telling a patient something in VR and then you get to play the role of the patient seeing yourself explain things to them Wow, so you kind of learn learn bedside manner There are lots of simulators that use real instruments, right that are hooked up to sort of force feedback machines So you are using a tweezer and you can actually replay surgeries, right that have actually gone right or wrong and play with those as well
玩那些给你手术体验的游戏和模拟，现在是培训医生和外科医生的关键部分。例如，有一个模拟器可以教你如何与病人互动，你首先是一名医生在VR中告诉病人一些事情，然后你可以扮演病人的角色，看着自己向他们解释事情。哇，所以你学会了床边礼仪。有很多模拟器使用真实的仪器，对吧，它们连接到某种力反馈机器上。所以你正在使用镊子，你实际上可以重放手术，对吧，那些实际上做得对或错的手术，也可以玩这些。
And in fact, we know that people who trained in these simulators have six times lower rate of accidents and other issues happening that there's less complications. So those skills are very transferable, right? Would you learn in these games and simulators you can use in real life? I mean, we talked earlier about sort of the value of making mistakes. I mean, obviously, if you're a surgeon,
事实上，我们知道在这些模拟器中受过训练的人发生事故和其他问题的几率低六倍，并发症也更少。所以这些技能是非常可转移的，对吧？你在这些游戏和模拟器中学到的东西可以在现实生活中使用？我的意思是，我们之前谈到了犯错的价值。我的意思是，显然，如果你是一名外科医生，
the value of making a mistake to you is that you learn to be a better surgeon, but the cost is that the patient in the table in front of you is paying a very heavy price. The simulation essentially allows you to do the learning without having the cost. And I understand the same principle is now being rolled out in many other areas of industry, including truck driving. I understand there are simulators to help truck drivers have fewer crashes. Yeah, what's fascinating is playing realistic truck driving simulators gets drivers to actually both get much less crashes but also use less fuel. So what's cool about a game right is you might spend 40 or 50 hours before you have a risky event happen in real life, but in games we can
犯错对你的价值在于你学会成为一名更好的外科医生，但代价是坐在你面前桌子上的病人正在付出非常沉重的代价。模拟本质上允许你在没有代价的情况下进行学习。我了解到同样的原则现在正在许多其他工业领域推广，包括卡车驾驶。我了解到有模拟器可以帮助卡车司机减少碰撞。是的，令人着迷的是，玩逼真的卡车驾驶模拟器可以让司机不仅减少碰撞，而且还能减少燃料消耗。所以游戏很酷的一点是，你可能在现实生活中发生风险事件之前会花费40或50小时，但在游戏中我们可以
force you to have that risky event happen many many times. Driving the rain, driving the rain in the middle of a fog storm, you know, drive with wind, you know, against you. And you can get through all those experiences in a compressed period of time, so you make all your mistakes up front rather than later. And that seems to have a long-term effect on people's skills and abilities. So some years ago at North Carolina, a man named Paxton Galvanack came across an awful crash on the highway and what he did in the next few moments made national news. Here's a clip of him talking about what happened.
强迫你多次发生那种风险事件。在雨中驾驶，在雾中驾驶，你知道，顶风驾驶。你可以在压缩的时间内经历所有这些体验，所以你把所有的错误都提前犯了，而不是以后。这似乎对人们的技能和能力有长期的影响。所以几年前在北卡罗来纳州，一个名叫帕克斯顿·加尔瓦纳克的人在高速公路上遇到了一场可怕的车祸，他在接下来的几分钟里所做的事情上了全国新闻。这是一段他谈论所发生事情的片段。
I witnessed a truck flip over several times and I was the first person to stop my vehicle and I figured if I was the first person there I'd be the person I could save these people and I witnessed two people that needed to be pulled from the vehicle. I saw that one of the people there had a severed fingers and i actually helped him control his bleeding by grabbing a towel and controlling it and then a uh... a plane closed soldier came up to the accident and said you did a great job you know i see what you did you control this bleeding this may have helped them all from what i learned in america's army yes all from what he learned from america's army what was going on here if in
我目睹了一辆卡车翻了好几次，我是第一个停下车的人，我想如果我是第一个到那里的人，我就是能救这些人的人，我目睹了两个人需要从车里拉出来。我看到其中一个人手指断了，我实际上通过抓起一条毛巾并控制它来帮助他控制出血，然后一个便衣士兵来到事故现场说你做得很好，你知道我看到你做了什么，你控制了这种出血，这可能帮助了他们，所有这些都来自我在《美国陆军》中学到的。是的，所有这些都来自他在《美国陆军》中学到的，这里发生了什么？如果
well america's army was a large-scale shooter game, sponsored by the US Army. And it was designed to recruit soldiers, right, to give them an experience of playing a game, it was an advertisement. In fact, at its height, it was actually the number two reason after patriotism that people said that it was why they were listing in the army.
嗯，《美国陆军》是一款由美国陆军赞助的大型射击游戏。它的设计目的是招募士兵，对吧，给他们一种玩游戏的体验，这是一种广告。事实上，在它最鼎盛的时候，它实际上是人们说他们参军的第二大原因，仅次于爱国主义。
So it was actually a incredibly effective game. But one of the really interesting things and talking about making something sort of boring and gauging in order to get the power to heal people in the game, to unlock the medic class in the game, you had to sit through a really boring slide show. You'd actually go into a barracks in your game and you'd sit down at a desk and then you'd watch a slide show about first aid. All right, Privatez. We're now going to cover combat
所以它实际上是一款非常有效的游戏。但真正有趣的事情之一，谈到让一些无聊的事情变得引人入胜，为了获得在游戏中治愈人的力量，为了解锁游戏中的医疗兵职业，你必须坐下来看完一个非常无聊的幻灯片。你实际上会进入游戏中的营房，坐在桌子旁，然后观看关于急救的幻灯片。好了，列兵们。我们现在要涵盖战斗
life saving or CLS. And then your gun was turned into a number two pencil and you had to fill out a scantron form. And if you got all the answers right after multiple hours of training, you got the power to heal people. It looks like everyone figured this one out. Good job, everyone. Let's move on to the next section.
救生或CLS。然后你的枪变成了一支二号铅笔，你必须填写一份扫描表格。如果你在经过几个小时的培训后答对了所有问题，你就获得了治愈人的力量。看起来每个人都弄明白了。做得好，大家。让我们进入下一部分。
So that learning stuck around, right? So that man that you just heard from was able to actually help someone and help save their life by the skills they learned in a game because they want to unlock the medic skill to be able to play a different role in the game that other people are playing. What I love about this example Ethan is that in some ways you're teaching people something that you need to teach them that involves effort. You know you're teaching them first aid in the rules and when to apply what.
所以那种学习留存了下来，对吧？所以你刚才听到的那个人能够真正帮助某人并帮助挽救他们的生命，通过他们在游戏中学习到的技能，因为他们想解锁医疗兵技能，以便能够在游戏中扮演其他人正在扮演的不同角色。我喜欢这个例子的一点是，伊森，在某种程度上，你正在教人们一些你需要教给他们且涉及努力的事情。你知道，你正在教他们急救和规则，以及何时应用什么。
And doing that in some ways requires, if you will, sort of, a didactic instruction, but by embedding it in a game, in some ways, you take the effort out of the learning and you make people focus on the game rather than on the learning. Exactly. And I think that is, you have this kind of interesting combination where the game is kind of driving you forward, but the learning. Exactly. And I think that is, you know, you have this kind of interesting combination where the game is kind of driving you forward, but the lessons are real. And that's often makes teaching with games really hard.
并且在某种程度上这样做需要，如果你愿意的话，某种说教式的指导，但通过将其嵌入到游戏中，在某种程度上，你从学习中去除了努力，你让人们专注于游戏而不是学习。完全正确。我认为这就是，你有一种有趣的组合，游戏在某种程度上推动你前进，但学习。完全正确。我认为这就是，你知道，你有一种有趣的组合，游戏在某种程度上推动你前进，但课程是真实的。这通常使游戏教学变得非常困难。
It's one of the things that we've struggled with in our efforts to build games for teaching is making sure the game is engaging and interesting, but also that the lessons you're learning are the real ones, right? Otherwise, you can pick up the wrong kinds of lessons from the game. So what's right about America's Army is the motivation that happened to sit down and watch these videos and take the test and do this right was inside the game itself.
这是我们在努力构建教学游戏时所挣扎的事情之一，确保游戏既引人入胜又有趣，但你所学的课程也是真实的，对吧？否则，你可能会从游戏中获得错误的课程。《美国陆军》正确的地方在于，坐下来观看这些视频并参加测试并做到这一点的动力就在游戏本身之内。
But the actual process of learning wasn't necessarily the point of the game, right? So you picked it up on the side. Companies are also increasingly using games to meet their business goals. I understand that Jeep wants created a game that allowed players to drive one of their vehicles over very rugged terrain.
但实际的学习过程并不一定是游戏的重点，对吧？所以你在旁边学会了它。公司也越来越多地使用游戏来实现他们的业务目标。我了解到吉普车曾经创造了一款游戏，允许玩家驾驶他们的车辆在非常崎岖的地形上行驶。
What was the thinking behind creating this game? And what was the effect on sales? I can have you play a game that highlights the characteristics of what makes my company great. So if I want to emphasize rugged roads, I can put you in a rugged road and a Jeep and I can even put it you in a competitor vehicle. And you'll get a great experience
创造这款游戏的想法是什么？对销售有什么影响？我可以让你玩一款突出我公司伟大特征的游戏。所以如果我想强调崎岖的道路，我可以把你放在崎岖的道路和吉普车里，我甚至可以把你放在竞争对手的车辆里。你会得到很好的体验
and you'll sort of get a real visceral understanding of why my product is better in some way. And so that ends up increasing sales in the long run. In some ways, this is sort of akin to the car salesperson saying, why don't you keep the car for a few hours and drive it around? And as you drive the car, you get to sort of have a feel of the car, but of course, there are only certain things you can do when you're driving a test driving a car. You can't drive it over a cliff or drive it over rugged terrain. I mean, you have to bring it back into the dealership in good form.
并且你会对为什么我的产品在某些方面更好有一种真实的直观理解。所以这最终会在长期内增加销售额。在某种程度上，这类似于汽车销售员说，为什么你不把车留几个小时开一开？当你驾驶汽车时，你会对汽车有一种感觉，但当然，当你试驾汽车时，你只能做某些事情。你不能把它开下悬崖或开过崎岖的地形。我的意思是，你必须以良好的状态把它带回经销商处。
The simulation in some ways allows you to test out all the possibilities of the car, and in some ways also wets you to the car. It engages you in how the car is operating. Exactly. That idea that you are connected to this product that you've used it already, that you have this sort of implanted, good feeling and memory.
模拟在某种程度上允许你测试汽车的所有可能性，在某种程度上也让你对汽车产生兴趣。它让你参与到汽车的运作方式中。完全正确。那种你与这个你已经使用过的产品相连的想法，你有一种植入的、良好的感觉和记忆。
Because again, I can set up a game to put you in a circumstance where you feel really good about that car. As opposed to in real life, where hopefully the test drive goes well, but maybe traffic's really bad, or maybe you end up having an annoying conversation with the salesman. In a game, I could control that.
因为再一次，我可以设置一个游戏，把你放在一个让你对那辆车感觉非常好的环境中。而不是在现实生活中，希望试驾顺利，但也许交通真的很糟糕，或者也许你最终与推销员进行了恼人的谈话。在游戏中，我可以控制这一点。
Do you worry at all that in some ways, the power of games can in some ways lead bad actors to use games for bad purposes here and selling people products that might actually not be the best products, but the games are really addictive. I mean, I can see a story of how this could actually turn out badly, that the addictiveness of power or engagement of games can be used for bad ends. Yeah, I think that we do worry.
你是否担心在某种程度上，游戏的力量在某种程度上会导致不良行为者在这里将游戏用于不良目的，向人们推销可能实际上不是最好的产品，但游戏确实非常容易上瘾。我的意思是，我可以看到一个关于这可能会变得糟糕的故事，游戏的上瘾性或参与度可能会被用于不良目的。是的，我认为我们确实担心。
Games can be held in a way, way does gamifying stock trading make people more willing to make bad investments in stocks the way they would when they're gambling. I'll say that I generally, you know, and it's always up for active debate, the most studied areas of like, do games make people more violent, for example, or are they, you know, purely addictive in a way that other things aren't? Those don't seem to be panning out. It doesn't seem like game violence causes real-life violence. It doesn't seem like that, you know, games are uniquely addictive compared to other kinds of activities.
游戏可以以某种方式被持有，游戏化股票交易是否会让人们更愿意像赌博时那样进行糟糕的股票投资？我会说我通常，你知道，这总是处于积极的辩论中，研究最多的领域，比如游戏是否让人更暴力，或者它们是否是，你知道，以其他事物所没有的方式纯粹上瘾？这些似乎并没有成功。游戏暴力似乎不会导致现实生活中的暴力。游戏似乎并不像其他类型的活动那样具有独特的上瘾性。
But I think we should be cautious about it. And I think it's a form of media. I mean, media is powerful. So in the end, our research shows that games are effective, but they don't replace work. So I think the games at work piece is something to be thoughtful about and concerned about. But I think that the danger is not huge, right? Because people are aware of the dreams of being games in real life. There are also, I think, many games being designed to actively improve the public good. And
但我认为我们应该对此保持谨慎。我认为这是一种媒体形式。我的意思是，媒体是强大的。所以最后，我们的研究表明游戏是有效的，但它们不能取代工作。所以我认为工作中的游戏是一个需要深思熟虑和关注的问题。但我认为危险并不大，对吧？因为人们意识到在现实生活中成为游戏的梦想。我认为还有许多游戏旨在积极改善公共利益。并且
they've been created by either nonprofit organizations or by researchers at universities like yourself. I understand that European researchers and partnership with Dutch journalists have created a game called the fake news game where players create fake news themselves. They get badges and followers for making use of the strategies they learn like impersonating someone else or inciting powerful emotions or even creating conspiracy theories. And eventually they can create an entire fake news empire. Now some of this sounds very disturbing. What was the point of a game like this, Ethan? One of the things that's interesting about games
它们是由非营利组织或像你这样的大学研究人员创建的。我了解到欧洲研究人员与荷兰记者合作创建了一款名为“假新闻游戏”的游戏，玩家自己创造假新闻。他们因为使用他们学到的策略而获得徽章和追随者，比如冒充他人或煽动强烈的情绪，甚至制造阴谋论。最终他们可以创造一个完整的假新闻帝国。现在其中一些听起来非常令人不安。像这样的游戏的意义是什么，伊森？关于游戏有趣的事情之一
is they put you in other people's shoes. And one of the clever things that this game is doing in this fake news game is it's asking you to be the bad guy. How would you exploit people? And it turns out that in actual controlled experiments, that this game actually increases the ability of people who play it to spot fake news in the real world because they understand the motivation for creating fake news. They understand the techniques people would do to use that. And then they can when they play the game, they learn those techniques and become more immune to it in real life.
是它们让你站在别人的立场上。而这款游戏在假新闻游戏中做的聪明事情之一是它要求你成为坏人。你会如何剥削人们？事实证明，在实际的受控实验中，这款游戏实际上增加了玩它的人在现实世界中发现假新闻的能力，因为他们理解创造假新闻的动机。他们理解人们会使用这种技术的技巧。然后他们可以在玩游戏时学习这些技术，并在现实生活中对它产生免疫力。
So there's sometimes an advantage to role-playing as the bad guy. Similarly, we're hoping to achieve herd immunity. You know, just as with regular biological vaccines, if enough people have at least some level of psychological immunity, the misinformation virus won't have a chance to take hold and spread as fast and as deep as it has up until now. I understand you've created a game where your students have to go on a mission to the Planet Saturn in the year 2087. You will help lead humanity to the future. You are about to take part in the year 2087. You will help lead humanity to the future. You are about to take part in the Saturn Parable. Tell me what happens in the game and what students take away from it.
所以扮演坏人有时是有优势的。同样，我们希望实现群体免疫。你知道，就像常规的生物疫苗一样，如果足够多的人至少拥有某种程度的心理免疫力，错误信息病毒将没有机会像现在这样快速和深入地扎根和传播。我了解到你创建了一款游戏，你的学生必须在2087年执行前往土星的任务。你将帮助带领人类走向未来。你即将参加2087年。你将帮助带领人类走向未来。你即将参加土星寓言。告诉我游戏中发生了什么，学生们从中得到了什么。
Yeah, so it's actually been a lot of fun as the culmination of a lot of my work. I've been building games for teaching. And this one takes place, like you said, on a sort of doomed mission to Saturn. The year is 2087, and humanity has left Earth behind, heading out into the solar system, colonizing Mars, and looking out even further. But one thing holds them back, the lack of water.
是的，作为我许多工作的结晶，这实际上非常有趣。我一直在构建教学游戏。正如你所说，这个游戏发生在一个注定失败的土星任务中。时间是2087年，人类已经离开了地球，前往太阳系，殖民火星，并向更远的地方看去。但有一件事阻碍了他们，那就是缺乏水。
And it includes elements from escape rooms, and we brought in a science fiction writer to help us write some of the plotline. And the idea is that by putting people in a fictional setting, it puts everyone in an even playing field. So no one's been on a mission to Saturn. So there's nobody who has more knowledge than another. It's the quiet person in the room
它包括了逃脱房间的元素，我们请了一位科幻作家来帮助我们编写一些情节。其理念是，通过将人们置于虚构的环境中，它让每个人都处于平等的竞争环境中。所以没有人去过土星任务。所以没有人比其他人拥有更多的知识。房间里安静的人
has just as much knowledge as the loud person, the older person, the younger person. And we give them a set of problems that are general problems the teams encounter. It's sort of a failure simulator for teams. So there's issues with communication in the team. Things in the mission start to go wrong and explode. Can they coordinate in the right way?
和吵闹的人、年长的人、年轻的人拥有同样的知识。我们给他们一系列问题，这是团队遇到的普遍问题。这是一种团队失败模拟器。所以团队沟通存在问题。任务中的事情开始出错并爆炸。他们能以正确的方式协调吗？
Can they avoid information problems that happen in real life? Can they avoid group think? Can everybody get their head in the game so they can coordinate and avoid kind of process failures that the team suffer from? And so in the end, part of the reveal is all the things you've experienced in the game are actually just the kind of problems you face and work all the time with this fictional setting.
他们能避免现实生活中发生的信息问题吗？他们能避免群体思维吗？每个人都能把头脑投入到游戏中，以便他们能够协调并避免团队遭受的那种流程失败吗？所以最后，揭示的一部分是你在游戏中经历的所有事情实际上只是你在工作中一直面临的问题，在这个虚构的环境中。
So everything we talked about, putting a compelling story and competition and systems on top of it, but in reality, you're learning about the kinds of failure that people have all the time at work. I understand you've also built games on how to launch a startup, and it seems to me that some of the skills in the planet Saturn game would also apply to being an entrepreneur of sort of juggling and thinking about the number of different things you have to plan for and anticipate and guard against. Yeah, and most of the time how you learn to be an entrepreneur
所以我们谈论的一切，在它之上加上一个引人入胜的故事和竞争和系统，但在现实中，你正在学习人们在工作中一直拥有的那种失败。我了解到你还构建了关于如何启动初创公司的游戏，在我看来，土星行星游戏中的一些技能也适用于成为一名企业家，即杂耍和思考你必须计划、预测和防范的许多不同事情。是的，大多数时候你学习如何成为企业家的方式
is you have to try being a founder and start a company. And that's a really expensive thing to do. So we've built a fake game where people live through running a company over the course of multiple weeks and real time and all the events that happen in real life happen. We built fake zoom, fake Slack, fake Dropbox. So you're actually interacting with customers and crises are occurring. And you get to learn the lessons that you would in real life, but without the risk and without knowing whether you're without having to have a good idea first.
是你必须尝试成为创始人并创办一家公司。这是一件非常昂贵的事情。所以我们构建了一个虚假游戏，人们在几周的时间里实时经历经营一家公司，现实生活中发生的所有事件都会发生。我们构建了虚假Zoom、虚假Slack、虚假Dropbox。所以你实际上是在与客户互动，危机正在发生。你可以在没有风险的情况下学习你在现实生活中会学到的课程，而且不需要知道你是否必须先有一个好主意。
And the early evidence is that it seems to make a big difference in people's entrepreneurial ability. I've actually had students who played the game contact me a couple years later when they're running their own company and referring to events that happen in the game as if they happen in real life. Wow. One of the things we were trying to do is open this stuff up to the world. We actually have a 90 minute version of the game that anyone can play at our Warton
早期的证据表明，它似乎对人们的创业能力产生了很大的影响。我甚至有玩过这个游戏的学生在几年后经营自己的公司时联系我，并提到游戏中发生的事件，就好像它们发生在现实生活中一样。哇。我们试图做的事情之一是向世界开放这些东西。我们实际上有一个90分钟版本的游戏，任何人都可以玩，在我们的沃顿
Directive site. People want to try it out. They're welcome to. You know, some years ago, I remember the New York Times published an interactive tool on their website that let people figure out how to allocate the national budget. So, you know, the newspaper basically says, here's the amount of revenue we have, here's it's for what we have to spend on, here are the different priorities, how would you divide up the budget?
指令网站上。如果人们想尝试一下，欢迎他们。你知道，几年前，我记得《纽约时报》在他们的网站上发布了一个互动工具，让人们弄清楚如何分配国家预算。所以，你知道，报纸基本上说，这是我们拥有的收入金额，这是我们必须花费的，这是不同的优先事项，你会如何划分预算？
So in other words, you know, ordinary people, ordinary citizens got to play the role of Congress. What I found remarkable about the game was how much it engaged people in policy questions, instead of simply presenting them with didactic information or ideological positions. People were saying, how would I balance this if I had to do it myself? As people got to explore the trade-offs, I had the sense that even reduced some of the partisan rancor we see in the news all the time. So I feel like the potential for games in terms of improving things that are in the public interest is actually quite vast.
换句话说，你知道，普通人、普通公民扮演了国会的角色。我在游戏中发现引人注目的是它在多大程度上让人们参与到政策问题中，而不是简单地向他们呈现说教式的信息或意识形态立场。人们在说，如果我必须自己做，我会如何平衡这一点？当人们开始探索权衡时，我有一种感觉，它甚至减少了我们在新闻中一直看到的党派纷争。所以我感觉游戏在改善公共利益方面潜力实际上非常巨大。
I agree. I mean, you know, there's all the elements come together here, right? So games make something that would seem really boring, like budget balancing, engaging. You're trying to solve a puzzle now. And also you get to see how other people are answering it. So there's social competition in comparison. And it makes a complex topic, like the budget feel senseical, right? One of the, my favorite examples of a game that engages people in policy, even they don't know it is SimCity. And I think maybe you played it, many, many people do.
我同意。我的意思是，你知道，所有的元素都在这里汇集在一起，对吧？所以游戏让一些看起来非常无聊的事情，比如预算平衡，变得引人入胜。你现在正在尝试解决一个谜题。而且你还可以看到其他人是如何回答它的。所以有社会竞争和比较。它让一个复杂的话题，比如预算，感觉很合理，对吧？我最喜欢的游戏例子之一，让人们参与政策，即使他们不知道，是《模拟城市》。我想也许你玩过它，很多人都玩过。
People start playing like fifth grade. And if you actually look at the number of variables people are balancing in SimCity, so they're trying to manage police coverage and economic development and firefighting and sewage, there'd be over like 450 variables that they're maximizing. And if you tried to tell me that you teach a fifth grader
人们从五年级开始玩。如果你真的看一下人们在《模拟城市》中平衡的变量数量，所以他们正在尝试管理警察覆盖范围和经济发展以及消防和污水处理，会有超过450个变量是他们正在最大化的。如果你试图告诉我你教一个五年级学生
about 400 aspects of city planning, it would seem insane, but in a game it all seems natural. And so the idea of a game to build perspective, to understand the complex systems we're in, bodes really well for educating and complex topics like climate change. So there's a lot there that's really powerful. What's your vision for how we should think about games
关于城市规划的400个方面，这看起来很疯狂，但在游戏中一切看起来都很自然。所以游戏建立视角、理解我们所处的复杂系统的想法，对于教育气候变化等复杂话题来说是非常好的预兆。所以那里有很多非常强大的东西。你对我们应该如何思考游戏有什么愿景
in the workplace and in the public square, Ethan? I mean, if based on all of the work and thinking that you've done, what do you think is missing in our public conversations about games or even in our attitudes about the role of games? Games are here to stay, people love them. So I think the question is what can we learn from games? And I think it's not that we can, you know, turn work into a game and then work become as amazing,
在工作场所和公共广场，伊森？我的意思是，如果基于你所做的所有工作和思考，你认为我们在关于游戏的公共对话中，或者甚至在我们对游戏角色的态度中缺少了什么？游戏将继续存在，人们喜欢它们。所以我认为问题是我们能从游戏中学习到什么？我认为不是我们可以，你知道，把工作变成游戏，然后工作变得如此惊人，
but we can take aspects of games that make work compelling or make learning compelling and apply those. That simulation aspect we talked about competition, the idea that you understand what you're trying to do and have clear rules, clear rewards, adjust difficulty level to someone's difficulty level in life. I think we should be asking how can we take aspects of games beyond just sort of the simple, let's have points and use those to make work and life and policy decisions more intelligently. policy decisions more intelligently. Along with David Edderay, Ethan Malik is the author of Changing the Game, How Video Games Are Transforming the Future of Business. Ethan, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
但我们可以采用使工作引人入胜或使学习引人入胜的游戏方面并应用它们。我们谈到的模拟方面，竞争，你理解你正在尝试做什么并有明确规则、明确奖励、根据某人的生活难度调整难度级别的想法。我认为我们应该问我们如何才能采用游戏方面，而不仅仅是简单的，让我们有积分，并利用这些来更聪明地做出工作和生活和政策决定。更聪明地做出政策决定。与大卫·埃德雷一起，伊森·马利克是《改变游戏规则：电子游戏如何改变商业未来》的作者。伊森，感谢你今天加入我的《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Christian Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Next week in our work 2.0 series, we look at how to avoid being knocked off course by distractions. Our unsung hero today is Alex Muntiano. He's a listener and hidden brain is his favorite podcast. He says, I really enjoyed the episodes that have a personal story combined with fascinating psychological research findings. Some time ago Alex decided to become a supporter of our show on Patreon.
谢谢你邀请我。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、克里斯蒂安·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。下周在我们的工作2.0系列中，我们将探讨如何避免被分心打乱计划。我们今天的无名英雄是亚历克斯·蒙蒂亚诺。他是一位听众，《隐藏的大脑》是他最喜欢的播客。他说，我真的很喜欢那些将个人故事与迷人的心理学研究发现相结合的剧集。前段时间，亚历克斯决定成为我们在Patreon上的节目支持者。
Alex, we are so grateful to have your support. It means a lot to our team. Speaking of unsung heroes, if you haven't yet done so, please check out our new podcast, My Unsung Hero. The episodes are short, usually around 5 minutes, and we think they'll provide you an emotional boost. If you're having a down day, listen to one of these episodes, it will restore your faith in humanity. You can find My Unsung Hero wherever you get your podcasts, and if you like it, be sure
Alex，我们非常感谢您的支持。这对我们的团队意义重大。说到那些默默无闻的英雄，如果您还没有听过，请去看看我们的新播客《我的无名英雄》(My Unsung Hero)。每集都很短，通常在5分钟左右，我们认为它们会为您带来情感上的慰藉。如果您心情低落，听听其中一集，它会重拾您对人性的信心。您可以在任何收听播客的平台上找到《我的无名英雄》，如果您喜欢它，请务必
to subscribe so you'll get every episode. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
订阅，这样您就不会错过每一集。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆(Shankar Vedantam)。再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。